but we got some news in that front you
think this is this is the end you think
that they're going to start opening up
the states and everything's gonna no no
we're going the other direction Oregon
has announced they're reinstating their
Mass mandates and we have this study
from act we have this story from axios
now I know YouTube is very nitpicky on
what you can or can't say about covet
for whatever reason they just ban
they're ban happy if I can't read axios
I don't know what I can read so new data
on coronavirus vaccine Effectiveness may
be a wake-up call a new pre-print study
that raises concerns about the MRNA
vaccine's Effectiveness against Delta
particularly pfizers has already grabbed
the attention of top Biden
Administration officials the study found
the Pfizer vaccine was only 42 percent
effective against infection in July when
the Delta variant was dominant quote if
that's not a wake-up call I don't know
what is a senior Biden official told
axios driving the news the study
conducted by inference and the Mayo
Clinic compared the effectiveness of the
Pfizer moderna vaccines in the Mayo
Clinic Health System over time from
January to July overall it found the
moderna vaccine was 86 effective against
infection over the study period Pfizer's
was 76 percent modernas was 92 percent
against hospitalization and Pfizer's 85.
but the vaccine's effectiveness against
infection dropped sharply in July when
the Delta variance prevalent in
Minnesota had risen to over 70 percent
moderna was 76 percent effective against
the infection and Pfizer was only 42
percent effective the study found
similar results in other states for
example in Florida the risk of infection
in July for people fully vaccinated with
moderna was about 60 percent lower than
per people people fully vaccinated with
Pfizer although it is yet to be
peer-reviewed the study raises serious
questions about both vaccine's long-term
Effectiveness particularly pfizers
quote based on the data that we have so
far it's a combination of both factors
says venki Sounder sound uh Rajan I'm
trying to pronounce that right a lead
author of the study the modern vaccine
is likely very likely more effective
than the Pfizer vaccine in areas where
Delta is the dominant strain and the
Pfizer vaccine appears to have a lower
durability of Effectiveness 42 now we
saw Israel they made similar claims that
a large portion of their of their the
people in hospitals were fully
vaccinated and the effectiveness is
being reduced I'm not going to tell you
what to do because I don't give medical
advice you go talk to your doctor about
your medical advice this is coming from
the Biden Administration we're getting a
statement from the Biden Administration
we're getting the Mayo Clinic we're
getting a study on this where do we go
what do we do they're going to bring
lockdowns back aren't they well you got
to assume that the virus is going to
mutate again it mutated into the Delta
strain and now I saw it Lambda they're
suspecting yeah and they were like we'll
have to go to the numbers after all the
Greek letters are gone but I mean it's
similar to what the flu does it tends to
be mutate that's why they haven't had a
virus that stops the thing you can just
from season to season help you reduce
infection and I think that's what we're
seeing here whether or not you want to
create a new vaccine every for every
strain every time I don't know you know
we kind of got to rely on data for that
and I see so much of it well I mean I
think the thing is we're headed it's
endemic we're headed towards covet as
something that just is part of our life
in the same way that the flu is part of
our life right like and it's part of
something we deal with every year I mean
there's a flu shot available a new flu
shot every year right that helps you out
against the variants they think are
flowing around and reduces the severity
that's where we're headed towards the
covet now
um what does that mean for your behavior
I think you know I'm seeing people like
freaking out and lockdowns and mass I'm
like no no no no no none of that because
like that that's a pandemic measure
that's a we're trying to eradicate it
that's we're trying to get it completely
eliminated and so and we're doing a
short-term measure until we get to
vaccines and and other mechanism but now
we have vaccines and vaccine technology
um and so I think that's where we need
to think we need to push this going like
fight against mandates and lockdowns and
instead say look we need to embrace the
idea that I I don't think we should
fight nearly as hard against like
booster shots as we should against like
continued Mass mandates and lockdowns
right because if it is endemic then
we've got to be like okay then this is
like then this is finally like the flu
and we need to as a society treat it
like the flu maybe more severe we have
more severe and that's kind of scary
actually more communicable I think is
really the key yeah because uh I guess
the scary thing is if it becomes a
seasonal thing I mean this this is It's
you lose your sense of smell you lose
your taste you get fatigued you know
yeah that's a that's that's creepy but
we got this from NBC News check this out
FDA poised to okay third vaccine dose
for immunocompromised people the move
would be the first authorization of
additional dose in the U.S
boosters are common I mean were there
the really interesting question were
there were there tests on three doses or
were there tests on the third dose
improving like as if if Pfizer as they
say is only 42 percent of at affecting
after infection after two doses like is
a how much does a third improve things
oh man it just it just feels like we did
a lot of things that didn't work and
they keep just saying we'll just keep
doing the same thing over and over again
because they don't know what else to do
right like they have to do something
they feel like they can't do nothing and
sometimes
you know we blame the authorities but I
mean it also starts with a huge chunk of
the population being absolute paranoiax
about it yes I mean at a point you know
I mean this is just something did you
did you guys hear people continue to to
blindly trust the authority on this
right like we talked about this last
time at first it was two weeks to slow
the spread it was we need to make sure
hospitals don't get overwhelmed and then
it was we have to make sure there are no
new cases and then we have to wait for
there to be a vaccine no no there is a
vaccine but it's not working right you
missed the lockdown again you missed one
part of that it was first it was you
know 15 days to slow the spread then
Cuomo killed 15 000 people oh that's
right yeah then it was okay we got to
stay locked down a little bit longer the
15 days thing was kind of like they're
like hey we have a bug bombing service
coming to your house you need to vacate
for two weeks we're gonna make sure we
kill the bugs and then you're like okay
and you leave your house you give it all
up you wait after two weeks they're like
yeah we didn't get all the bugs uh we
don't know if it's working right it's a
new bug now yeah different bugs same
chemical doesn't seem to work exactly
right but we're gonna keep doing it and
I need access to my house dude
in Germany they're advising people to
get a third shot because a nurse was
accused of giving people saline instead
of the vaccine what yeah and they said
they didn't know why she did it but that
she had posted anti-vax stuff or vaccine
skepticism online
think about how insane that is in the
other direction like certainly we can
talk about mandates and lockdowns being
bad it's extreme but how Extreme as it
is is it if someone goes to the doctor
the doctor recommends them medication
they say thank you doc I will agree to
this medication and the nurse goes I
ain't given the net and secretly gives
them something that's the problem with
rushing stuff out
if they die man too right right crime
like you need to go to jail for a long
time for that you don't get to you don't
get to deceive someone into getting uh
there was actually I remember it was
just saline it was just saline which is
harmless but that sounds criminal um and
these were elderly people too yeah yeah
criminal dude I'm sure you inject me
with something I didn't ask for man and
you deceived me into thinking it was the
thing that would protect me from the
disease I need protection from and then
I go ahead and die from that disease
because I was unprotected like
manslaughter about people just having
informed consent and making the choices
that they that's what's right for them
to think that this nurse would decide I
I don't care what you think think I
don't care what you've you've read I
don't care what the doctor said that's
insane right to jail right away and do
they have any way to track which
particular patient she gave sailing to
or their records no I think they were
saying it was like several thousand whoa
maybe maybe several times I could be
wrong incarcerated at the moment that's
the situation I I said I I think the
article is Reuters I said they weren't
sure if she had been arrested or charged
but
wow dude maybe to Israel and that's why
the vaccines have been less effective
this is this is the opposite of of
informed consent and that's what I'm all
about like you go to your doctor your
doctor says here's the news you say you
ask them questions here's a story I saw
what do you think and then they they
they're honest with you they show you
the studies they explain to you in great
detail and you were informed if someone
was to switch out your medicine for
anything that is that is not informed
consent that is them
that's that's that that's not that's the
opposite it's it's it's it's just crazy
man people are losing it I'll put it
that way I uh I just looked the story up
and she injected
8600 people so who knows how responsible
she is for possible deaths holy cow did
you guys this is really interesting um
you guys follow Brett Weinstein yeah
he's been talking about I've seen a
little bit of it I wouldn't say I've
been following it but he he tweeted out
one of these doctors who said heads up
that the front line Coalition of doctors
whatever these are the people who are
always talking about Ivermectin and
hydroxylchloroquine stuff like that said
it's not working they said that their
treatment is no is not working on people
with uh with a Delta variant and a bunch
of it responded saying like it never did
work a lot of studies contradict this
and that's why people were critical of
you but I think it's really interesting
two things one they were saying that
this one doctor said they've experienced
people with the Delta variant in the ICU
and their standard treatment protocol
didn't work
interestingly as well their standard
treatment protocol calls for wearing
masks so even the people who are being
censored because they're talking about
these other treatments
are telling people to wear masks that
that I find interesting like who I don't
who who are the people saying not to
wear masks when it comes to potential
sickness you know what I mean like where
it's it's interesting to me I don't know
it's it's a weird situation I mean I've
said for a long time that I hope one of
the things that comes out of all this is
that you know it is now a social Norm
that if you're coughing in public you
should be wearing a mask right like if
you're say if you're if you're knowingly
sick like stay home and if you are going
to go out wear a damn mask and don't try
and reduce the amount you spread to
everybody else that's the other crazy
thing too like that's fair when I see
people walk when I go outside I see
someone with a mask I'm like I don't
know whatever right why would I I don't
care I don't think about that stuff
people people smack talk me all the time
on the internet I don't care I ignore it
I'm doing my thing you know and I think
if I see somebody outside wearing a mask
I'm you know if they're sick good what
if it's in a movie what if the
characters in TV shows and movies start
having masks on
dude so I rewatched uh The Big Short you
guys remember oh yeah yeah
one of the characters one of the one of
the characters Brad Pitt character it's
like the big thing is he's a kind of a
weird guy very eccentric and you know he
comes to the airport and he's wearing an
n95 and using hand sanitizer and it's
like that's the model of his
eccentricity wow and now it's like
everyone does that everyone turned into
the weird eccentric hypochondriac this
is the interesting thing seeing the you
know the front line Coalition you know
whatever these doctors
um who have been talking about
Ivermectin when they come out and they
say like hey Delta variant the stuff's
not working you know I just I'm like is
there's a vaccine you know what I mean
like would they would they support that
it seems like they're just doing studies
on what they've been doing which is a
very intelligent and ethical thing to do
as a scientist as doctor so but if you
haven't looked into the other stuff yet
but they're just kind of showing the
flaws and and you know how it's changing
the Delta variance different than the
other yeah but should they then be like
our new protocol includes getting a
vaccine and wearing a mask or whatever
which is funny because then it goes
right back to the CDC and fauci it was
so weird to fight against the vaccines
because you figure I mean I remember so
many of the same people who were like oh
this isn't a big deal and oh we should
head for herd immunity we're then the
ones who are the biggest vaccine
Skeptics and that was always very
strange to me because I felt like the
best the best argument against all the
sort of social distancing Public Health
type measures was a vaccine that would
help protect you so that yeah that Trump
was responsible for right operation more
seed I also think people had a suspicion
that it didn't matter how many people
got vaccinated there was going to be
some push to continue the lockdowns
that's this is the problem I have look I
keep saying in farm consent I don't give
medical advice go talk to a medical
professional but when when in the story
after story after story comes out about
some guy being like Oh no I'm dying if
only at the vaccine or that woman in
Alabama where she was screwed up I take
their hand and they say please give me
the vaccine I say I'm sorry it's too
late I'm like dude come on
your nose morbidly obese people having a
heart attack or like smokers having
lungs I mean I guess they did that with
smokers having lung cancer not to think
about it but a lot but they certainly
don't do it with overweight people and
obese people
um they should well maybe they shouldn't
I think at the very least yeah I think
there should there should be you want
you want to do a great reset let's have
a great race at people's mental health
their physical health their personal
responsibility because they watch less
CNN so that would be the aboga plant if
you want to do that you ever study that
thing this is African psycho
psychoactive plant that makes people
just destroys addiction you take it you
come out of it with no addiction it's
amazing but it's like one of the most
visceral you know grotesque experiences
you can have I've heard that sounds
terrible they'll get it other than that
how are you gonna how are you gonna
great reset people's eating habits well
I think just look it's in the words of
Frederick Douglass I believe it's easier
to build strong men than repair broken
ones I think it more or less comes down
to educating the Next Generation I don't
think it's a matter of anything else
than that you you try to help build
virtue in the population which is uh
already there but most of your hope is
in educating the young my concern is
that kids mimic their parents and if the
parents unwilling to change their diet
the kid may be eating healthy at home
because he's forced to but when they
leave the house they're going to start
mimicking what they knew
hmm yeah I mean it's possible so you're
saying the end is an I I'm saying iboga
is not the end of the world uh no the
end is just beginning
a long time my friends you know what man
it feels like a slow motion collapse how
did I describe before like it's a giant
Joe Biden and the building falls down
and then he grabs it and he can't hold
it up no no I'm sorry that's a bad way
to put it Joe Biden walks up to the
building like a Godzilla Joe Biden
punches a hole in the foundation and
then starts falling and he catches it
and he's slowly easing it down to the
ground yeah it's a revolution but I
think the the Spanish term uh revolute
is that what it is means to turn forward
return to revolve to return forward it's
actually to return forward which is like
a slow falling forward of course it's
then going to circle and spiral and
continue thanks for checking out this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time